joining me now oklahoma congressman mark
wayne mullen
congressman this
hello this is an amazing story i mean
it's just outrageous how angry how mad
are you that after everything that you
in that organization that nonprofit went
through you you have the state
department trying to take credit for it
you know i would like to say i i was
surprised but i wasn't along the way
we had multiple ambassadors that we
spoke to that had told us when we were
trying to arrange uh what we call rat
lines because with these same people we
try to get out to a kaya and we couldn't
get the state department to open the
gate we tried on the 28th the 29th and
the 30th multiple times and when they
said that anybody that wanted to leave
could leave that's not true because you
had to go through three taliban
checkpoints and each one of them would
charge between 500 to a thousand dollars
a person to cross those checkpoints so
that's why the other countries was going
out and getting their citizens and
bringing them back but not not the
united states but at the orders from
either secretary blinken or or president
biden uh and so when they when we
started trying to find other places to
take them out of through other countries
and set and set up rat lines
which which we have been successful
doing we have right now 23 other u.s
citizens amsets and safe houses in
different locations outside of kabul
that are waiting to get out too when we
started trying to find and work with
embassies around there they told us they
said mr mullen or rhett mullen we have
been instructed not to assist you in any
way
now this is embassies telling me that
washington dc told them not to assist us
in any way and it's a bold face lie when
they're still out there saying that this
was a successful evacuation this was a
successful mission when rachel the truth
is i wouldn't be there if it was
successful and other organizations
wouldn't be there the sentinel
foundation wouldn't be there if it was
successful and then when we worked for
literally 48 almost around-the-clock
hours trying to negotiate with the
taliban to release
miriam to be able to come across the
bridge
and then and then blink and puts out a
statement that says that the taliban was
helpful and released to them i will tell
you at three o'clock yesterday morning
it central standard time at three
o'clock yesterday morning they had
threatened to kill her because i was on
the phone with her and they had
threatened to kill her if she approached
the uh the checkpoint again right and
that doesn't sound like they're working
with us but blink and he goes out there
and wants to take credit for it and it
infuriates me because they continue to
lie to the american people i'm sure
you've had some time to think about this
entire ordeal and you have to wonder
and i'm sure you have and tell me what
you think the answer is why would the
state department stand in the way of you
helping when they didn't do it
you know my personal opinion is um
they're they're trying to squash this
story they want this bad news to go away
as soon as possible and and i i truly
believe that their way to do that is
just not allow it to be a story anymore
right and why else would they not allow
american citizens you know a while ago
you talked about uh the airplane setting
and measure sharif mezz and the state
department not giving them clearance to
to to land well we've been working on
several of those planes in fact miriam
was on one of those planes before we
pulled her off and and what we had
suggested to the state department i made
this suggestion i called them and said
why don't we put let one plane leave
that only has amsets american citizens
and sivs which are special immigration
visas that are granted to come to the
u.s why don't we just fill up one plane
and allow them to come in and they said
they said well no we we can't because we
won't know who's on the manifest sheet i
said i will give you the passports and
all the documentations of the sivs to
show who's on there and they still
wouldn't grant us the opportunity to
leave right on top of all of this
congressman the worst part and maybe
it's not the worst part but it's one of
the parts is that the state department
and the administration is actually
trying to smear you they're accusing you
of showboating um and you probably
wouldn't have had to do this if they had
done their job send in special forces um
you know send in you know the navy seals
or better yet
gotten our americans out before they
closed in withdrew this from this
operation or from this country yeah how
about how about use the plan that that
president trump had where we were going
to uh uh close um the kabul airport a
second to last and keep up bagram
airport until last that way we can still
have air support and have and have a
military personnel present to make sure
this didn't happen how about just how
about just use that plan and instead of
blaming on everybody for me i never
wanted this to get to go public we never
went in there to try to go public we
wanted to be as quiet as possible the
sentinel foundation is non-political
yeah this isn't they don't want
publicity like this and so when we when
we started teaming up with them we made
a we made a decision not to go public
with any of it but the state department
leaked a conversation that was
completely misinterpreted that i had
with a uh with another ambassador when i
when i asked him right who told you you
couldn't work with me and they said we
can it came out of dc and i said sir
either you tell me who told you or
you're going to hear from me in a
different capacity because we're going
to have a hearing on this and i'm going
to find out eventually who told you not
to work with us to get american citizens
out and he apologized for freezing it
wasn't his fault he was following orders
from the state department in washington
d.c absolutely absolutely well
congressman we really appreciate it and
it took an mma fighter and a congressman
to help this operation get through we're
grateful and i'm sure that family is
true rachel i was
yeah i want to make it clear i was a low
man on this tour i know i worked with
great operators on the signal foundation
that these are tier one individuals and
special forces guys that i was i was the
least of them all and i was just blessed
to be able to work with them well we're
blessed to have you and that team thank
you so much congressman
thank you rachel hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else